okay so this is go with me I'll just get
the plateau away really fast I really
want to talk about this one okay
so there's an episode where Jake is
going to couples naive eight says you
know couples have to smooch and stuff
it's a romantic movie so Finn thinks
about taking a bubble gum with or
people's and and he's trying to figure
out how to water and stuff and Jake's
giving advice and then Marceline comes
in starts giving advice for a frigging
hilarious reveal that was great under
the blanket and that's great that was
great that is so good and and she's
given more and more advice and her
interests do not match people's very
much you know she likes to wrestle and
run with wolves and stuff maybe showing
Finn the game long really good
bubblegum finally just tosses and
Mouse's your nuts until you're not nuts
you can't come back through the kingdom
and Marceline is like pretty much even
yeah Jory was saying it to like you know
these two should be a couple what the
hell and then they they kinda do but it
turns out that Marceline you know just
wants it to be a friend and nothing else
and that's kind of what Finn wants to he
just wants to go to couples thing
because everyone else is going and this
is what you're supposed to do and so
they go as friends they see them kiss
and they're like you know that's gross
and they tear up the screen the another
great joke that definitely could tear us
apart and he tears the screen that's a
great joke I love that
wolves together and stuff okay enough of
that these two should really be a couple
I'm already working on my fanfiction
right now and I don't know where the
show goes but they should be a freaking
couple is that we thought about before
but then we see them like you know
run-in with the wolves and everything is
like this totally makes sense because
they're both totally insane and crazy
blood for different reasons and I don't
know I was totally all over that man I
was totally all over then I thought it
was cute I don't know it's like it never
clicked and then when you see them
actually hanging out it's like oh
actually this totally makes sense why is
he going for people's there or whatever
you know it's like because they're like
okay they're opposites and that can
obviously work too but it's like look so
much more fun
could be had marceline and him are a
couple it doesn't make sense that you
know his girlfriend would be a vampire
it's like Finn the awesome adventure guy
I mean it's like jake has the Rainicorn
thing that speaks Korean it's like why
not a vampire for fit it just makes
sense okay I'm sorry I like this idea I
really like this idea I don't know I
can't be like hey you people go you
craters to the show go make that cuz
it's already made but still it's like go
make that if ever goes a different
director I don't know maybe it goes
enough better interact I have no idea
but it's like I don't know I I like that
I'm sorry I'm you know uh detailed yeah
you know did my fanfiction all right
there I'm sorry you go ahead what you
think but isn't it awesome like you know
when they're going they're running with
the wolves and everything and like and
she's acting crazy at first he doesn't
know what to do and then like suddenly
he gets more into it and it's like yeah
and then he lets the wolves in to
Bubblegum's place and she's like ah he's
like well what's wrong what's wrong and
it's like it's just awesome they they
should hook up he is 13 old is she oh
yeah she's like a million um ok sorry
about a thousand ok so you know she
looks 920 I'm not even talking he's 13
okay but come on couples still that's
young love come on they can do that I
mean that fat guy yo go on go to those
schools nowadays and start saying
thirteen-year-old start dating go for
them like 98 years year-olds it's okay
well she's technically probably close to
98 that's Remzi Oh
so what 98 year olds and 13 year olds to
hook up not usually but in this case
maybe I don't know it just feels right I
can't fight my urges to see a 13 year
old and a thousand year old get together
a beautiful harmony that sounded really
creepy I'm realizing but they this
shuttle makes it work I think it may
kick you out of my house
and not allow you until you stop acting
and saying it's I don't she doesn't look
a thousand actually that's a good
question though it's like okay they
throw this really ancient number on her
but I mean how when she was bitten or
whenever cuz right she gets bitten and
then she stays that age is that the idea
yeah pretty much okay like what age is
she supposed to be I assume like like a
15 or something like that well no
actually I've had this question and I
will actually get back to the episode
unlike him so take a interview with the
vampire okay the young girl is bitten
and she's like 12 or something like that
so let's say a hundred years past she's
technically 112 but no matter how you
would look at her she would always be
that 12 year old so would she ever fully
be able to fully mature into a woman
well I'm sure she yeah okay she can't
really go through like the changes and
stuff they get that's kind of true you
know that's really messed up yeah she'd
be yeah whatever okay I'm with the
episode two things I really really liked
um pretty much any time Marceline comes
on screen the bass sound gets really
really like loud they bring out the bass
obviously because she plays the bass but
I like the fact that you hear that doo
doo doo doo
I think it's a nice little touch that
you know it shows Marceline that's not
like your theme yeah and then the other
part I really really liked and it was so
fast is when they're at the theater
they're watching and they look at
Rainicorn and Jake and they're making
out
they're making out in like a truck that
has a dead body there I didn't even
notice that there's a skeleton that's
like right behind them like not even
hidden or anything it's just like mmm
like you're the skeleton like I'm like
that's kind of dark so like you know you
know what it could be maybe just cuz you
don't really see people drive in this
world maybe they just found like that's
Brian their apocalypse saying they just
found the drive-in and the people that
were stuck there just like oh hey movie
they just ran whatever movie what's in
there woman I made no I totally didn't
notice that now here's a question I
would like to know your thoughts on and
even new people at home while watching
so they're watching it and the old
trailers if you will for movies have the
let's all go to the hobby which are
talking food I was thinking that too
like what's this film recently then or
like it that were all no but like if
they saw a movie like an old movie and
they're watching that would they be like
oh my god that could be my relative
yeah that's or you know think of that
before they'd be like that's blasphemy
like you're the the characters talking
and stuff they were still like whatever
weird candy people and stuff right like
in the movie the ones that were kissing
and stuff I didn't think so they looked
kind of human are they I think so yeah
Oh
Jory okay all right desert before they
had the whole popcorn and everything
like briefly on the screen yeah yeah I'm
kind of shocked they didn't well with
that said that I'm almost shocked they
didn't do some more like a throw a lion
or something like yeah
like you know let's just like my uncle
yeah that goes through the weird humans
or whatever it's a and maybe maybe it's
too obvious I don't know but no I
Marceline and fin being a couple way too
obvious I mean I don't know that's also
don't do like a love triangle thing with
it like know if it means more Marceline
and Finn possibly game together but I
know what they're gonna do they're gonna
have like you know they're gonna make it
look like Finn and Marceline get
together it's like no no that's not it
has to be him and bubblegum cuz that's
what we set up and she's the good girl
and stuff and that's no fun I want to
see the good girl not get the good guy
for once you know I want to see like you
know just a couple that's like so why do
you watch Disney all the time okay
well well yeah that's what I thought not
giving the beast he was a jerk yeah he
was a jerk because he was like 12 when
he was turned into this monster but
there you go it still still works
oh I'm sorry if my daughter was at the
door and so I was like please help me I
need something in my daughter slam the
door in their face rock on breathe
Wow even if she was like a millionaire
they had like all these rooms that she
could like you know flood open and have
security watch 12 alone at home crazy
person outside what's he supposed to be
12 he was really really good yeah I
guess like when you do like the actual
math he's like really yeah maybe it
could be 10 that's it doesn't make that
make it there's still no kid they don't
make him look like a little but that's
what we point worried rock on kid for
shutting the door on that crazy psycho
split like face how women wait if he was
like how can he own a castle if he's
only 12 because it's Disney and Disney
is dumb okay I don't think you're
supposed to beat while I think it's
supposed to be grown-up I thought you
supposed to be like a grown guy okay and
how many years was he the Beast oh
you're the Disney person Oh way to say
how long she's with him it could be a
winter could be a year I don't know
crazy why are we on Beauty and the Beast
I don't know yeah arable facility talk
about real romance with Marceline at fit
that's gonna work or it should work make
that work catheters pry so much
fanfiction about that already is real
romance me and my wife see you later
yeah that's just fake artificial